seul moyen de traverser plaques de verre
c'est la case et il est l'un des plus
grands magiciens français actuel
françois mornag joue devant une salle
comble à blois
6 et tours sont des grands classiques de
l'illusion il subjugue par leur
virtuosité c'est vraiment bien fait on
voit on voit pas les effets on voit
c'est vraiment bien dissimulé il est
vraiment très agréable et très fort tu
vois comment il fait mais c'est magique
ce magic est ce que tu as découvert
comment il fait c'est tout il y en a que
je savais faire mais il y en a que je
sais faire mais non mais pas aussi bien
que ça
leur magie les illusionnistes les
transmettre aux générations futures est
le véritable secret réside dans l'art
qui met à s'en servir les colombes c'est
bien les gars ça aussi
le côté la difficulté qnx de secret dont
le public se fait toute une toute une
idée il faut vraiment le faire passer au
second plan le la première chose c'est
cette chose imperceptible très difficile
à définir qui est bien le le talent
l'énergie le contact on va mettre avec
le
seul à bord avec un public
et surtout un art du spectacle un
thé à la rue miss pau
la magie est un art total que l'on doit
à robert houdin le plus fameux des
magiciens français né à blois il ya 150
ans le prestidigitateur est un un acteur
qui joue le rôle du magicien ce qui est
l'une des phrases
vrai de qui se puisse dire et
robert houdin on lui doit aussi d'avoir
fait en sorte que c'est à rayonne et
qu'on soit prêt un petit peu plus au
sérieux et ne tire yale de
prestidigitateur se succèdent sur la
scène de la maison de la magie jusqu'à
dimanche idéal pour se bercer
d'illusions
[Musique]